and New Yorker writer Atul Gawande it's
a collection of essays on how surgical
mistakes happen and the human element
that makes saving lives possible this
talk from politics and prose bookstore
in Washington DC is just under an hour
politics in prose bookstore and I'm
really happy to welcome you here tonight
I'm sorry I have to move this down I'm
happy to welcome you here tonight as I
was telling Atul go on the I my father
was a physician and he was interested in
health policy as he was in the Public
Health Service for during the Second
World War and then he remained
tremendously interested in health care
health care for the indigent health care
for the elderly and a national health
policy in general and I found out
something that I didn't know which his
Atul Gawande has shares a lot of those
interests that he worked during the
Clinton campaign and in the early part
of the Clinton administration on health
care policy both during the campaign and
at HHS so I feel that the even though I
didn't know that that there's a certain
way in which concerns about health care
and health policy imbue this series of
essays and that the although the subject
is somewhat the education of a young
resident and his observations on what
he's learning and what he's seeing as a
physician as a young physician that it's
placed in a larger context than one
would expect and I think that we are
really indebted for the way in which
Atul Gawande has translated some of the
more technical everyday concerns of a
physician into language that
we lay people can understand and I know
that all of us wish that more physicians
could do that thank you very much for
coming tonight well thank you everybody
for coming out and it's a special event
for me to be here in Washington my wife
is from Alexandria Virginia and over
many years I've had a lot of time spent
down here and then I did have the
special opportunity now almost
embarrassingly 10 years ago to work in
the Clinton administration on health
care policy and spend a wonderful more
than a year year and a half and also at
times difficult time during during that
period well I went on to medical school
and my medical training and and into
surgery of all things and about four
years years ago I found myself in the
odd and wonderful position of getting to
write occasional essays about medicine
and science for the New Yorker magazine
about two years into it I was approached
by a publisher with the very flattering
idea of trying to put together my ideas
about how medicine worked together for a
book and I said of course why I'd love
to and and and now this I'm both nervous
and proud to say is the result
I'm as I mentioned still a young doctor
a surgical resident nearing the end of
my eight years in training and surgery
and this book arises out of the
intensity of that experience I've come
to think of medicine as a strange and
remarkable and also sometimes disturbing
business and writing became my way of
thinking through what it is that we
actually do we have arrived in a sense
at a new and important and also
uncertain juncture in medicine on the
one hand medicine has become
extraordinarily complex and the
wildering and also powerful capable of
extending people's lives and making
people's lives better whether they have
heart attacks or cancer or depression on
the other hand the notion that doctors
are gods is long gone and people
are now expected to take medical
decisions into their own hands
in many cases make decisions for
themselves and not simply do what your
doctor tells you to do yet no one I
think has really prepared anyone for
this whether doctors or patients no one
I think in particular has shown people
how it is that medicine really works
what decisions matter how decisions are
made how much uncertainty there is and
how that uncertainty is dealt with and
so what I tried to set out to do in
writing this book is try to show exactly
that show how things go right how things
go wrong and why
and in the process tell a few stories I
hoped I think the thing that struck me
most
upon entering the field of medicine is
how fundamentally human and endeavor it
turned out to be when we hear about
medicine today when the media writes
about medicine what we hear about is the
massive amount of knowledge and the new
technologies and all this amazing
ability of 21st century medicine but
what we experience what we find when we
get in close is a much Messier more
fragile reality of an individual doctor
and an individual patient trying to sort
through it all you have a belly pain and
it's the amazing know-how and the
medicines and the technology and clear
answers that you want but what do you
get it's just a doctor someone with bad
hair and and a little annoying laugh and
a weak chin and some things they know
and some things that they don't we all
want medicine to be I think an orderly
field of knowledge and procedure but it
isn't some of this can be helped and
some of it can't there are then I think
three reasons that things in medicine
don't always turn out the way that we
expect them to or that we imagine that
they're supposed to three layers in a
sense to the distance between theory and
practice and these three layers make up
well very cleverly I should add the
three sections of my book
so first and perhaps most upsetting as a
cause for imperfection of medicine is
fallibilities and in the chapters in
this section I consider everything from
as someone described earlier the
dilemmas of the learning curve and
needing to practice upon people and
learning what we do to mistakes and how
they occur to how well a profession like
ours deals with problem individuals all
of these I think are worries that
patients certainly have and they're also
things that I don't think we in medicine
have explained or even necessarily
understood particularly well a core
element and I think the hardest to grasp
element is that it's good doctors not
bad doctors who are the ones who make
the bulk of the mistakes and trying to
think through what that means for all of
us is part of what I had been trying to
do especially in this the stories in
this section the second section and the
second reason behind the imperfection of
medicine is about how much mystery still
remains in the human condition how much
of medical science so remains terra
incognita and so in one chapter I
consider not rare problems but very
common problems like the troubles of a
patient with a chronic pain it was one
of those patients with a terrible back
pain he was on disability he had been an
architect and and had had an injury from
which things only got worse and worse
and yet when x-rays were done and MRIs
were done nothing structurally wrong
with his back could be found a very
common situation precisely the situation
for many people with disabling back pain
he's also it's actually the situation
that makes many of us in medicine want
to run away when one of these patients
come to the clinic because we have we
feel like we have so little to
necessarily offer and what I want to
understand was why what it is we know
what it is we don't know and what how it
is we deal with how much we don't know
another chapter I examine the story of a
woman with an intractable case of nausea
and vomiting that progressed to the
point that she would even begin to bleed
from her own stomach then
Oh doctor could either explain or treat
there are more chapters considering what
may be a kind of weird range of problems
from for example the story of a
450-pound man with worsening obesity who
decided to undergo radical surgery to
allow him to well to stop him from
eating altogether another about a
newscaster who sought medical help
because she blushed so severely that she
could not know well she lost her job as
a newscaster the I think the striking
thing is that we act and even do major
operations
despite at times rather unclear evidence
about what precisely to do and it's not
surprising that in such that that these
situations would end up being a real
struggle for doctors and for patients I
think it's also not surprising that the
results can be less than we want or
expect them to be and that surprises can
happen along the way the third and I
think critical and also inherent element
in medicine is uncertainty even if we
eliminated the errors and even if the
science of human afflictions were
completely understood there is still an
inevitable uncertainty in what we do and
whether the diagnosis you've made is
correct and whether the treatment you've
chosen will really turn out to do
everything that you hope it will and I
think it's this uncertainty that makes
perfection unachievable and also makes
medicine so hard and so in this section
I try to think about uncertainty from a
number of angles a look at autopsy
findings we're still even to this day
40% of autopsies will turn up in this
diagnosis and yet we have on the other
hand a decline in autopsies we have a
case in another story of a mother
accused of murdering her eight children
although physicians had first thought
they were victims of sudden infant death
syndrome and in the final two chapters
there were there are several cases where
I hope we begin to see how doctors and
patients together sort out how to make
decisions in the face of uncertainty and
how sometimes people
well and sometimes not so well coming
here today I was thinking about what I
would read to you and I think what I'd
like to read to you about is is to pick
up one of the threads running through
the book that might help show the
direction the book goes and the thread
is is really a puzzle
it's the puzzle of how medicine can be
as deeply uncertain as it is at times
and as plagued by human fallibilities
but at the same time so successful so I
was going to take the beginning of the
very last chapter in the book called the
case of the red leg sure
seeing patients with one of the surgery
professors in his clinic one afternoon I
was struck by how often he had to answer
his patients questions I do not know
these are four little words a doctor
tends to be reluctant to utter we're
supposed to have the answers we want to
have the answers but there was not a
single person he had not he did not have
to say those four little words to that
day there was the patient who had come
in two weeks after an abdominal hernia
repair
what's this pain I feel next to the
wound she had said there was the patient
one month after a gastric bypass
operation why haven't I lost weight yet
there was the patient with a large
pancreatic cancer can you get it out and
to all the attending gave the same reply
I do not know a doctor still must have a
plan though so to the hernia patient he
said come back in a week and let's see
how the pain is doing to the gastric
bypass patient it'll be all right and
asked her to come back in a month to the
cancer patient we can try to get it out
and although another surgeon thought he
shouldn't given the tumors appearance on
a scan operation would be futile and
risky the colleague had said and he
himself thought the odds of success were
slim at best he and the patient who was
only in her 40s with still young
children at home decided to go ahead the
core predicament of Medicine the thing
that makes being a patient so wrenching
being a doctor so difficult and being a
part of a society that pays the bills
they run up so vexing is uncertainty
with all that we know nowadays about
people and diseases and how to diagnose
and treat them it can be hard to see
this hard to grasp how deeply the
uncertainty runs as a doctor you come to
find however that the struggle in caring
for people is more often with what you
do not know than with what you do
medicines ground-state is uncertainty
and wisdom for both patients and doctors
is defined by how one copes with it
there is I think in a sense of science
to managing uncertainty experience
matters for one thing and I mentioned
the learn
curve but also just as important is
simply being systematic about what we do
so let me take another chapter consider
a relatively simple surgical procedure a
hernia repair which I learned to do as a
first-year surgical resident a hernia is
a weakening of the abdominal wall
usually in the groin that allows the
abdomens contents to bulge through in
most hospitals fixing it
pushing the Bulge back in and repairing
the abdominal wall takes about 90
minutes it might cost upwards of $4,000
in anywhere from 10 to 15 percent of the
cases the operation eventually fails and
the hernia returns there is however a
small medical center outside Toronto
known as the shield ice hospital where
none of these statistics apply at sholde
Ice hernia operations often take from 30
to 45 minutes the recurrence rate is an
astonishing 1% and the cost of an
operation is about half of what it is
elsewhere there's probably no better
place in the world to get a hernia
repaired what's the secret of that
clinic success the short answer is that
the dozen surgeons that shole dies do
hernia operations and nothing else
each surgeon repairs between 600 and 800
hernias a year more than most surgeons
do in a lifetime in this particular
field shield Isis staff is better
trained and has more experience than
anyone else but there's another way to
formulate the reason for its success
which is that all the repetition changes
the way they think as Ellucian leap a
Harvard pediatric surgeon who has made a
study of medical air explains a defining
trade of experts as they move more and
more problem-solving into an automatic
mode with repetition a lot of mental
functioning becomes automatic and
effortless as when you drive a car to
work novel situations however usually
require conscious thought and workaround
solutions which are slower to develop
more difficult to execute and more prone
to error a surgeon for whom most
situations have automatic solutions has
a significant advantage the thrill dice
example then suggests that perhaps
physicians should be trained if anything
attacked mostly like machines one chilly
Monday morning I put on a green cotton
scrub top and pants a disposable mask
and a paper cap and wandered among the
cases in the shul dyes hospitals five
operating rooms to describe one case it
is to describe them all I watched three
surgeons operate on six patients and
none deviated even a step from their
standard protocol in a tiled box like
operating room I peered over the
shoulder of Richard sang a 51 year old
surgeon with a dry wit and youthful
appearance though we chatted during the
entire operation doctor Tseng performed
each step without pause almost absently
with the assistant knowing precisely
which tissues to retract and the nurse
handing over exactly the right
instruments instructions were completely
unnecessary the patient a pleasant
surprisingly composed man of about 35
who occasionally piped up from under the
drapes to ask how things were going
lay on the table with his lower abdomen
exposed and painted yellow with a
bactericidal iodine solution a plum size
bold was visible to the left side of the
hard bone of the pubis doctor Tseng
injected the skin with a local
anesthetic in a diagonal line from the
top of the man's left hip to the pubis
along the crease of the groin with a
number 10 blade he made a 4-inch slash
along this line in a single down stroke
revealing yellow glistening fat below
the assistant laid a cloth along each
side of the wound to absorb the mild
bleeding and pulled it open saying
swiftly cut down through the outer
muscle layer of the abdominal wall
exposing the spermatic cord a half-inch
cable of blood and spermatic vessels the
patient's bulge we could see now came
through a weakness in the muscle in the
muscle wall believed beneath the cord
which is a common sight sang slowed down
for a moment
checking meticulously for another hernia
along the area where the cord came
through the inner abdominal wall sure
enough he found a small second hernia
there one that if it been missed would
almost certainly have caused a
recurrence he then sliced open the
remaining must
layers beneath the cord so that the
abdominal wall was completely open and
pushed the bulging abdominal contents
back inside if you have a tear in a
couch cushion with stuffing coming
through you can put a patch on the
cushion or you can sew it back together
in my hospital we usually push the
hernia back in place a piece of sturdy
plastic like mesh on top and sew it to
the surrounding tissue it provides a
reliable reinforcement and the technique
is easy to perform but sang like the
other shoulder surgeons I asked scoffed
at the idea they viewed the mesh as a
hazard for infection since it's a
foreign body expensive since the mesh
can cost hundreds of dollars and
unnecessary since they get enviable
results without it so a saying and I
talked about such alternatives he sewed
the wall back together in three separate
muscle layers using fine wire making
sure that the edge of each layer
overlapped like a double-breasted suit
after saying closed the patient's skin
with small clips and removed the drapes
the patient swung his legs over the edge
of the table stood up and walked out of
the room the procedure had taken just
half an hour many surgeons elsewhere use
shield Isis distinctive repair method
but obtained ordinary rates of
recurrence it's not the technique that
makes Scholl dice great the doctors at
sholde ice deliver hernia repairs the
way Intel makes chips they like to call
themselves a focused factory even the
hospital building is specially designed
for hernia patients their rooms have no
phones no televisions and their meals
are served in a downstairs dining hall
as a result the patients have no choice
but to get up and walk around thereby
preventing problems associated with
inactivity such as pneumonia or leg
clots after saying left the patient with
a nurse he found the next patient and
walked him straight back into the same
operating room hardly three minutes had
passed but the room was already clean
fresh sheets and new instruments were
already laid out and so the next case
began I asked burns shield ice a son of
the clinic's founder and a hernia
surgeon himself
whether you ever got bored doing hernias
all day long I would know he said in a
spock-like voice perfection is the
excitement paradoxically this kind of
super specialization raises the question
of whether the best medical care
requires fully trained doctors none of
the three surgeons i watch operate at
the shoulders Hospital would even have
been in a position to conduct their own
procedures in a typical American
Hospital for none had completed general
surgery training Tseng was a former
family physician burn shield ice had
come straight from medical school with
no training no residency at all and the
surgeon in chief was an obstetrician yet
after apprentice inquiry assertions in
the world.the the lesson there are many
lessons to me about the sholde ice but
part of the lesson is certainly not only
that experience matters and that but
that being systematic about what we do
about really thinking about what it is
we do each day but even when all of that
has been accounted for even if you've
made a protocol out of everything in an
algorithm for every problem there is
still a place for an a role for
intuition and I thought I'd read another
passage that tries to explain what I
mean
starts out with a bit of a philosophical
discussion in a 1976 essay the
philosophers Samuel Gore votes and
Alistair McIntyre explored the nature of
phal ability why would a meteorologist
say
failed to correctly predict where
hurricane was going to make landfall
they saw three possible reasons one was
ignorance perhaps science affords only a
limited understanding of how hurricanes
behave a second reason was ineptitude
the knowledge is available but the
weatherman may fail to apply it
correctly
both of these are surmountable sources
of error we believe that science will
overcome ignorance and that training and
Technology will overcome ineptitude the
third possible cause of error the
philosophers posited however was an
insurmountable kind one they termed
necessary phal ability there may be some
kinds of knowledge that science and
technology will never deliver Gor of its
and MacIntyre argued when we asked
science to move beyond explaining how
things say hurricanes generally behave
to predicting exactly how a particular
thing say Thursday's storm off the South
Carolina coast will behave we may be
asking it to do more than it can know
hurricane is quite like any other
hurricane although all hurricanes follow
predictable laws of behavior each one is
continuously shaped by myriad
environment uncontrollable accidental
factors in the environment to say
precisely how one specific hurricane
will behave would require a complete
understanding of the world in all its
particulars in other words omniscience
it's not that it's impossible to predict
anything plenty of things are completely
predictable Corvettes and MacIntyre give
the example of a random ice cube in a
fire ice cubes are so simple and so
alike
that you can predict with complete
assurance that an ice cube will melt but
when it comes to inferring exactly what
is going on in a particular person well
our people more like ice cubes or more
like hurricanes right now at about
midnight I'm seeing a patient in
emergency room obviously not right now
and I want to say she is an ice cube
that is I believe I can understand
what's going on with her that I can
discern all her relevant properties I
believe I can help her
Charlotte Devine as we'll call her is 49
years old and for two days she's had an
abdominal pain I begin observing her
from the moment I walked through the
curtains into her room she's sitting
cross-legged in the chair next to her
stretcher and greets me with a cheerful
tobacco Beaton voice she does not look
sick no clutching the belly no gasping
for words her color is good either
flushed nor pale her shoulder-length
brown hair has been brushed her red
lipstick neatly applied she tells me the
pain started out crampy like a gasps
pain but then during the course of the
day it became sharp and focused and as
she says this she points to a spot in
the lower right portion of her abdomen
she's developed diarrhea she constantly
feels as if she has to urinate she
doesn't have a fever
she is not nauseated actually she is
hungry she tells me that she ate a hot
dog at Fenway Park
two days ago and visited the exotic
birds at the zoo a few days before that
and she asked if either might have
anything to do with this she has two
grown children her last period was three
months ago she smokes half a pack a day
she used to use heroin once but says
she's clean now she once had hepatitis
she has never had surgery I feel her
abdomen it could be anything I think
food poisoning a virus appendicitis a
urinary tract infection and ovarian
cysts a pregnancy her abdomen is soft
without distension and there is an area
of particular tenderness in the lower
right quadrant when I pressed there I
feel her muscles harden reflexively
beneath my fingers on the pelvic exam
her ovaries feel normal i order some lab
tests her white blood cell count comes
back elevated her urinalysis is normal a
pregnancy test is negative
i order an abdominal CT scan I am sure I
can figure out what's wrong with her but
if you think about it that's a curious
faith I've never seen this woman before
in my life and yet I presume that she is
like the others I've examined is it true
none of my other patients admittedly
were 49 year-old women who had had
hepatitis and a drug habit had recently
been to the zoo and eaten the Fenway
Frank and had come in with two days of
miles lower right quadrant pain yet I
still believe every day we take people
to surgery and open their abdomens and
broadly speaking we know what we will
find not eels or tiny chattering
machines or a pool of blue liquid but
coils a bowel a liver to one side a
stomach to the other a bladder down
below there are of course differences an
adhesion in one patient and infection in
another but we have catalogued and
sorted them by the thousands
making a statistical profile of mankind
I'm leaning towards appendicitis the
pain is in the right place the timing of
her symptoms her exam and her white
blood cell count all fit with what I've
seen before she's hungry however she's
walking around she's not looking sick
and this seems unusual I go to the
radiology reading room and stand in the
dark looking over the radiologists
shoulder at the images of davines
abdomen flashing up on the monitor he
points to the appendix worm-like thick
surrounded by grey streaky fat it's
appendicitis he says confidently I call
the attending surgeon on duty and tell
him what we found all right book the
owari says we're gonna do an epidemic
this one is as sure as we get yet I've
worked on similar cases in which we
opened the patient up and found a normal
appendix from what I've learned looking
inside people I've decided human beings
are somewhere between a hurricane and an
ice cube
in some respects permanently mysterious
but in others with enough science and
careful probing entirely screw ttle it
would be as foolish to think we have
reached the limits of human knowledge as
it is to think we could ever know
everything there is still room enough to
get better to ask questions to learn
from knowing when our simple certainties
are wrong I'll go ahead and stop there I
forgot in my introduction to say what a
tremendous writer a really extraordinary
gift if anybody wants to come and sit on
the floor in front you are most welcome
I see a number of you back there that
might be more comfortable on the floor
there's a lot of room up here so if you
do if you can get it down and up you can
sit on the floor is no come all the way
up Catherine no no you shouldn't sit in
the aisle there's more room in front and
your wife's over here I also want to ask
you to use the mic in the center of the
room we have a mic it'll be better for
our audience when c-span and it will be
better for those of us who are sitting
here and it will take less time if our
tool doesn't have to repeat the
questions so make your way to the mic if
you please and then
okay yes sir do you hear me I can indeed
okay I'm an internist I work for the
Army at Fort Belvoir I wonder now that
you've had seven odd years in practice
if you had to do the clinton plan all
over again
leaving aside of the 2,300 pages in the
450 decision gates but the substance of
the plan how would you change it or
would you change or you do think it was
it was okay what I think the substance
of thank you for the question
so the substance of the plan amounted to
a couple basic principles we would cover
everybody and we would see to it that
the cost would be within a range so the
public could have some say over over
that and that fundamental reality I
would not change the I am in many ways
indifferent how we get there if it means
Medicare for everybody if it means that
we keep our private insurance system as
it is but subsidize it so people who
don't have it can get it I'm thrilled
and the whatever way it takes to get
there I think is very important
the notion though that we still have
well over 40 million people who simply
do not have coverage for basic aspects
of their care and then another 20 25
million who who have insurance coverage
that but turns out not to be good enough
if they get really sick I've seen it now
after seven years of being in training
and you see the difference it makes in
the care that people get and it only
convinced me more that that is what we
need but it will be a long time in
coming slow slow in coming I'm a
practitioner in another field and I've
found that pointing out mistakes of
fellow practitioners in that field in a
public way weeds to great problems and
I'm wondering about in your field if you
are already a member of the American
College of Surgeons have they expelled
you yet
and how is it that more surgeons have
not come forward to admit their mistakes
of which there are many well thank you
for that question you know I wrote this
book and have written some of the essays
I've written for The New Yorker with
some trepidation about how they would be
received by my colleagues by the people
who employ me and teach me and the truth
of the matter is as I've been shocked at
how well it's been received the American
College of Surgeons not only has kept me
in their midst I've been asked twice to
speak at their convention not at all
what I expected and it turns out that
that they're grappling with the very
same thing that that patients are
grappling with which is this new place
where doctors are on the one hand
understood to not be infallible where
patients are expected to take a stronger
role in making decisions and yet very
little of it has been well explained to
anybody and with without a clear sense
of how to move forward and so you have a
lot of doctors who are struggling with
the fact that we do make mistakes they
may be sued for them they may be accused
of being bad doctors for them and yet
it's still good doctors for whom this is
happening and so there is a struggle to
number one to understand what is going
on number two to be able to explain it
to the public and to ourselves in a way
that we can all grasp it and number
three to convey in some way the emotion
of that situation a lot of the mistakes
I talk about are my own and even now
have a hard time sometimes just telling
people or reading from those sections of
the book they are very painful to me
sometimes shameful experiences and yet
they are also the experience of every
physician and simply conveying that is
also something I think physicians who've
spoken to me feel like has been a
worthwhile effort and so I know that
there are and I've spoken to many
colleagues who disagree with some of the
things that I say
in this book but the criticism has been
constructive no one has told me they
wish I hadn't written it at all you know
what you were saying before is how human
medicine is and I think that's part of
the problem now what happens when I look
at medical training you know you may
have decided at age six or seven intend
to become a doctor so you've been
focusing you've been studying all the
time and undergrad everybody was at the
parties and you were studying doing your
pre med bit you were doing the med
school bit then finally after all these
years you go to the hospital got your
little white coat on and you get to talk
to patients and I see so many of them
have no idea how to talk to human beings
you know right and what happens is that
you know and I know that all good
doctors got to be good doctors by
practicing on poor people you got to
have that volume you know you're good
BlueCross BlueShield not gonna let
interns touch them not gonna let
students touch them so now you have a
group of medical students who tend to be
middle class upper class confronted with
lower class patients and their problems
communicating in the first place you
know so now you have so many people
complaining about the doctors really
can't talk to me cuz you've been trained
in science all your life so I have to
being a scientist all this time now you
got to become a human being some people
make the adjustment and some people can
you know and to medical questions one I
wanted to pin the sides you do a rectal
exam on it absolutely all right you know
doctor the fall I always say you got to
do that rectus and the woman who had the
blushing all times you see have
mastocytosis she did not I can tell the
doctor in the midst as well here well
you know the in its some way I think we
have to be careful about stereotyping
doctors in both ways the the the
physicians I know the young doctors I
know are all people who actually from
the very beginning cared about taking
care of people and yet have yes
struggled with understanding the science
I've been at surgical training for seven
years and it still astonishes me how
much further I have to go till I feel
I'm really good at simply the technical
part of what we do and then yes then
there's the human side of sitting down
and talking to people and remembering
that these are human beings with
individual problems and not just a
gallbladder in room three and and
grasping how to
bein begin to communicate with people
it's a retail business in some way to an
extent that he that surprises you you
know your and many levels along the way
just someone fitting shoes for people
and and understanding that it is a
humble position it is one in which
people are bearing themselves to you and
that it is a one person at a time kind
of situation is I think one of the
hardest things to convey to young
doctors and also to patients about what
is happening and so you don't want the
science divorced from the humanism you
do want people who know that it's a it's
a human being at the other end of your
stethoscope that you're listening to I
know I don't always meet that goal in
taking care of patients I get angry and
tired and flustered and there are some
patients I bond with and other patients
I don't the there are undoubtedly
differences of class and economics that
and race that come into that and and
it's one of the amazing things about
medicine is you meet everybody it's
unlike anything else there is you know I
think of medicine as the most complex
and ambitious endeavor that mankind has
ever attempted it is to take care of
every range a potential problem a and
misery that a human being and human body
can undergo take care of it for every
single person in the country and to do
it with the optimal amount of knowledge
and compassion that you can possibly
bring we are it's amazing to me that we
come close at all and of course we don't
come short and yet we do succeed to an
extent that still surprises me I'm also
a physician as psychiatrist who has
chosen at least for this point in time I
think somebody wants to become a little
closer than not to work because of some
of my own concerns about the environment
in which physicians are practicing
currently and so my question for you is
I'm sure you have read some of the
surveys that have been done amongst
physicians
looking at their professional
satisfaction some of their loss of
morale and and frustration just with the
practice of medicine part of that I
believe is attributable of course to the
changes in medicine and the environment
in which we're practicing the ways in
which we no longer have control over the
caring environment that we used to have
but in addition I think what your book
is is describing in terms of physicians
being able to accept their own phal
ability and vulnerability is another
source of stress and so these two
sources just in general could be thought
of as external stresses versus internal
personal stresses and based on your
experience of eight years I graduated
about 20 plus years ago but in eight
years I'd be curious to know what your
read is on the sources of demoralisation
and poor morale on the part of
physicians whether the the sources are
primarily internal or primarily external
thank you for that question
the I like you have seen these surveys
and understand also the experience of
physicians who feel like the pressures
of managed care and the insurance
environment and the number of patients
that you end up having to see nowadays
is a source of great unease takes some
some of the joy out of doing what we do
I've been struggle though that many of
the surveys from other countries where
they don't have those same pressures
show the same decline in morale and
where what I have come around to
thinking is that a lot of this comes
from simply the sheer fundamental change
in medicine itself everywhere the
physician is no longer unquestioned
everywhere the physician is no longer
necessarily on the pedestal and also
everywhere the pressures of the fact
that our technology makes a huge
difference it does matter what you do
for people in a way that it didn't
twenty years ago because we can do so
much for different situations and and
medicine has become in a sense
a team sport in a way it never was
before and so now you as a physician
have to have a great team of nurses to
work with a team of that includes
nutritionists and orderlies and visiting
nurses at home and administrative chiefs
and a lot of people who you now have to
cooperate with and also listen to and
not always have your judgment be the one
that matters the most and it's a world
in a sense that none of us were
well-prepared for so I think the sources
are still external to a great degree
because some medicine has changed so
much because it's become so much more
intense and technological and difficult
because so many patients are on in your
patient load people a typical internist
takes care of no matter what country
you're in two to three times as many
patients as they used to take care for
ten or twenty years ago and then you
combine that with as you said the
internal pressures the reality that
mistakes are made the stakes are only
grow higher the more that we can do
means there's more we have to get right
and so it compounds that internal sense
of fear of failure and I think being
able to think about it talk about it
explain it has been my way of coping
with a very intense and difficult
experience just going through my own
training it's been my way of
understanding it and remembering how
important and worthwhile it is what we
do before I was a doctor and we've
talked a lot about medical mistakes
which in the real world are known as
malpractice and the shocking thing to me
when I went to medical school in my 40s
why is that it's not just great
imponderables there are some things
we'll never understand but doctors are
trained not to look things up there are
no resources in a hospital for them to
look up they're supposed to keep a
little book in there the books are made
the size to fit in a jacket pocket and
that's all you take with you you're
supposed to remember everything
doctors feel that they can perform just
as well at 4:00 in the morning if
they've been on for 36 hours as they can
when they first get there everyone in
the real world knows that's not true
that there are things that could be
fixed we don't have to wait for mistakes
to happen the airline's don't wait for
crashes to figure out what to do to
prevent crashes we say we don't we don't
see what anything wrong and therefore we
need all this reporting
we don't need reporting we need common
sense thank you the well the I'm I
believe in what you say
the example that I sometimes talk about
is the notion that every time I pick up
prescription pad I feel like I'm an
accident waiting to happen
the right thousand prescriptions and you
know you're gonna get the decimal place
in the wrong place some of those times
you know that your handwriting is going
to be misread and what happens when that
happens and somebody actually is harmed
and dies as a consequence well you get
sued and this is a common it's the most
common mistake that occurs is medication
errors and what we what do we what have
we done for 20 30 40 years is we've sued
people and yet all the way along
certainly for the last 10 years we've
had a simple solution that would get rid
of 80% of medication errors and that is
to write the prescriptions on a computer
the that would get rid of the decimal
point errors that would make them
perfectly legible and yet
99% of physicians we don't do it it's
partly because of the way that the
public looks at our mistakes it's an
individual failure it's also part of the
way that we look at our mistakes we see
it has fundamentally individual failure
and if we miss the decimal point we
think God how can I've been so stupid
next time I'm just gonna pay more
attention and boy I'll never make that
error again but we know this is an
accident waiting to happen and yet we
still live with an old way of thinking
about things and so it's the lessons in
a sense of the engineers who have taught
anesthesia that by gosh why do you make
machines where you can turn the oxygen
down to zero everybody needs some oxygen
so don't even make them that way
rather than rely on somebody to remember
not to turn it down to that those
lessons are only starting to be learned
in medicine we've only begun to do the
research that looks points the finger at
how we how we do things rather than who
does them
dr. Guan D G tell us why young medical
student would leave New England and
moved to Little Rock Arkansas give up
his career and work for the Clinton
administration and also share at this
the ups and downs motion up and downs of
working during those early years so this
is drew computers as 'king the question
who was the doctor I got to know in
Little Rock Arkansas when I moved as a
26 year old to Little Rock you know when
I got offered the job to work for
Clinton I'm pretty sure it had something
to do with the fact that number one
President Bush Senior then was Sam had
70% favorability ratings coming off the
Persian Gulf War so no one thought
Clinton could possibly win number two he
got it he got paid next to nothing and
number three you had to move to Little
Rock and when I got there
folks like drew computers became great
friends and took good care of me
the what made a 26 year old do that my
god you got offered one of the best
opportunities you could ever have at for
someone like me so it was without
question that I jumped ship
I also cared about being involved with
the public being involved with public
policy and understanding how it is that
we make lives for people better both
inside and outside medicine the hard
part for me has been being back in in
medical training for such a long stretch
you don't get to think about these
things you're mostly focused on making
things go right for one individual
person and writing became my way of
being able to step back and and think
through these things again and to
remember what it is that that's
important what it is that that we do
well what it is we we don't do well and
sometimes to understand a lot of the
confusions that occur every day I'm
wondering what made you so thoughtful
and sensitive
and your and as well as your training
that's not my mother I I'm an
anthropologist naturally I wrote a book
called the scalpels edge the culture of
surgeons where I followed senior
surgeons work it's a wonderful book and
but what I found there was that it was
both in the selection of the care of the
cert the people who would become
surgeons and the training that made them
have this penchant for action this
certainty wanting certainty and a
tremendous discouragement of doubts and
people started out being decent human
beings and there was so much in their
training that discouraged this and I
wonder what it is that you went through
and what you can recommend in that that
training well I should warn you I mean
you know I may write very
compassionately but I'm not necessarily
that way when I'm when I'm with a team
of people that I want to make sure
everything goes right the you know the
the trick of writing has to do with
observing as clearly as you possibly can
and you get a lot of that from medicine
but the flipside is that cool detachment
doesn't necessarily serve all that well
necessarily in the in in the patient
arena and so I try very hard to be as
compassionate as I can be but I know
that I'm the same way you know part of
my fascination with surgery is precisely
the surgical persona it is the the
person who looks at situations where
there is uncertainty and information is
unclear and action is necessary and they
take it you know that saying sometimes
wrong never in doubt that's usually
taken as a criticism of surgeons is
precisely what I found fascinating about
surgery it's in a way what I wanted is
the wisdom to be able to act in the face
of uncertainty in the face of doubt and
and to do it with some steel and you
have to you can't do it blindly and the
worst surgeons are ones
have no fear the ones who go in with no
recognition of the doubts that that are
there but the best ones are ones who
know that their skills are imperfect
that they make mistakes and yet still go
on and so I think in the end I'm
probably not all that different from a
lot of Surgeons when you see me on the
wards and I think we do need to do a
better job of making sure in all of
medicine that we don't reduce people to
numbers and don't forget that our our
bluster has to sometimes subside and
leave room for patients to understand
that we can hold their hand or just sit
with them sometimes but but I'm not sure
I learned any differently for many of my
colleagues I think of many of my
colleagues as better positions than
myself take you back to the issue of how
we teach our profession and the whole
issue of see one do one teach one
and and and what do you think there
might be other alternatives in the you
know the 21st century if you're a pilot
and you fly for American Airlines the
first and you fly a 757 the first time
you fly it for real
you've got passengers on board and all
the training has been done on a
simulator and there are actually huge
areas where simulation is it has real
value in the training of physicians and
other health care practitioners for
example why on earth would you ever want
to learn to do a spinal tap for the
first time you know or a epidural
anesthetic on a mum was just about to
have a baby and this is your first time
around and I wonder how much you feel we
ought to be insisting that we change
this ancient profession of ours and
adopt some of them you know technology
that is they're unavailable for us well
it's the science of learning separates
into two parts the science of there's
the the learning before doing and then
there's a learning by doing and you'll
never get rid of the learning by doing
there is more we can do when it comes to
learning before doing including
simulation include
learning on animals and this applies not
just in the beginning of training it
applies throughout a doctor's entire
career my father is a surgeon in Ohio
where I grew up and he told me that 75%
of what he does today he was not trained
to do as a resident the reality of
progress in medicine is that every year
there is something new to learn for a
doctor that's part of what makes being a
doctor so exciting is that you're always
on a learning curve in in what you're
doing and how does he learn to do you
know a new laser comes out that he can
use to break up stones and how does he
learn to do it well he goes up to
Columbus which is about a hundred miles
from where I where we live and up there
a company might set up a lab for a day
where he gets to practice on an eggshell
tapping with the laser and then maybe
maybe though not often he they might
have a pig for him to try one time on
and then they'll send him a home with
the video and then there's got to be the
first person that he's got to give it a
try on and that's how learning works you
I think it is absolutely imperative and
worthwhile that we think harder about
how it is we learn to bring in more
learning before doing but I don't want
to soothe people too much by the notion
that that the learning curve can be
eliminated there will still always be
that first time there'll be the tenth
time and 15th time and the curve
continues to go on up so that for for
all of us the reality is that the that
perfection and progress can't occur
without practicing on on someone though
there is much that we in the medical
profession have to take as a lesson to
make that part better you know how do we
how does a surgeon reach a point where
he decides he's no longer competent to
operate and the answer is probably
because he hurts somebody will kill
somebody if you fly a 747 you get to
land it once a year in Chicago and a
crosswind of thirty seven miles an hour
and zero visibility and if you can't do
it
somebody marks your book and says this
guy shouldn't fly 747s anymore and we
need the same sort of system to reg
later ourselves and I think this is what
your your in particular or article the
learning curve has become for us and I
work in medical simulation and you never
mentioned it once but you've less well
down the path thank you thank you thank
you
earlier you said that good doctors make
more mistakes than bad doctors good no
no so I should the library it on that
bit good so you take the bulk of
mistakes that occur and most of the
mistakes by far are done in the hands of
good doctors rather than bad doctors bad
doctors probably make are more likely to
make mistakes but but by but by far most
doctors are well trained are
conscientious and are doing the best job
that they can and at the same time still
make mistakes so the net result is that
a lot of mistakes occur let me put some
numbers on this we had done a study out
of our research group herself in two
states in Utah Colorado we looked at
15,000 hospital patients and looked at
all their records and found that
reviewing them
97% had no no complications at all
things went just fine which is terrific
but 3% had serious complications that
would that involve death or disability
or prolonged hospital stays half of
those complications according to the
physicians who are reviewing the cases
were judged to be avoidable that is the
result of error now one percent success
a failure rate or error rate is on the
one hand sounds terrific
on the other hand when you consider the
thousands of people who get medical care
this translates into tens of thousands
of people who are harmed avoidable and
the question then is what can we make of
that what can we do of that and I think
we just have to well the hardest part
about the whole thing is grasping that
these are not just a handful of doctors
that simply need to be thrown out and
the problem would go away instead it
comes back to those questions like the
computer prescription pad that could
make such a difference or the machines
that can make such
difference.the there are a thousand
steps to taking care good care of a
patient even with a simple problem like
in pneumonia and we've only begun to
really look at the each of those steps
and figure out why it is that each of
those steps sometimes go awry Atul
Gawande
is a surgical resident in Boston and a
staff writer for The New Yorker
complications a surgeon's notes on an
imperfect science is published by
metropolitan books a division of Henry
Holt & Company visit Henry Holt calm